good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us i'm vanessa murphy in for
kirsten
good afternoon i'm brian loftis tonight
we are learning a bit more about those
involved in third days thursday's fatal
accident involving a box truck
and a group of cyclists it all happened
on u.s 95
right near searchlight since then
cyclist communities all around the
valley have been showing their support
a news now reporter madison kimbrough
live from the university medical center
with the latest details madison
yeah that's correct brian so one of the
cyclists injured was airlifted here to
umc trauma
in critical condition meanwhile the
cyclist community has really come
together to help
any way possible now take a look at the
footage that we shot yesterday where you
can see the extent of the scene
four men and one woman died yesterday
after a box truck
that was driving in the same direction
as the group cyclist veered into their
lane
killing and injuring several riders this
happened on u.s 95
south of boulder highway at mile marker
35.
as of now we know three people are
injured but we don't know their status
at this time
two were reported and transported
immediately to the hospital according to
nhp
trooper on scene the other person
injured did not seem to have
life-threatening injuries a fellow
cyclist friend and former metro police
officer michael anderson
was there yesterday and shared some
words
we do this nipton loop every year no
problems
this year we just
just in the wrong place at the wrong
time
anderson created this gofundme page for
his friends
on it he lists the names of the cyclists
who lost their lives
along with those that are still fighting
he says the main purpose of the go fund
me page is to ease some of the financial
strain
the families may be facing right now and
if you care to contribute to the go fund
me page we'll have a link up on our
website
of course we'll keep you posted
throughout the afternoon
as more information comes in about this
story reporting live from umc madison
kimbrough 8 news now